we have three letters that we can choose
from for this and then what they're
asking is okay two parts how many
four-letter words can I make with that
and then let's narrow it down to how
many of those four little words will
have exactly two B's in them okay
so let's give that a go when you are
thinking about I've got all these
options and it's kind of like a weird
replacement right again I like to draw
my I kind of call the pigeon holes in
fact this what I'm doing right now is
kind of as a general principle it's got
the pigeonhole principle
so it's I've got things to put into
pigeon holes and I then go through the
process of thinking about well okay
which a pigeon holster might put things
into and how many options do I have for
each of those okay so what we've got is
a four letter word
excuse me and the condition that I have
placed on the quality what is that two
of the letters have to be bees no more
no whew up okay
so if I have to be to I then get a
choice where do I put those because the
bees can be anywhere right so in order
to work out first where do I place them
okay how many ways can I help me spots
can I choose from right well I've got
four to choose from and I've got to
choose two of them okay so that's where
I can place the bees does that make
sense so it's like okay do you want to
pick position one or position to your
position through your position for you
pick two whichever you like and then I'm
going to put bees in them okay so that's
how many options I've got now after I've
done that right there were four spots
internal four spots in total right and
then I've taken two of them out of
action right so subtract two so that
means two remaining spots where I have
to choose what letter to go into them
right now let me just go back one step
when I did this I really should have
multiplied by what right cuz I picked up
those two spots and then I thought okay
how many choices do I have for what to
put in those spots and the answer is
only have one twist because they have to
be bees all right but now here for these
two spots that I have left right how
many choices do I have to put into those
spots and the answer is two right so
this is actually it should be two to the
power of two okay now you've got to be
really clear on what the twos the heat
because they're different
right let me just change it suppose they
will give us a five letter word suppose
was a firefighter and I have five spots
to begin with I have taken two of them
out of action right so now I've got
three remaining spots that need to be
filled
okay how many letters do I have to
choose from to put into those spots a or
C how about two choices right so how
many options are there and the answer is
well there will be two cubed all right
zombie sense because I'll do my pigeon
holes now right there are three spots I
can put two options in here right and
then two and there and then - and then
so it's two times two times two which is
too cute okay so this is base this base
it represents how many choices how many
possible things can I put into these
holes right and then this to the index
or this three it represents will know
how many spots do I have to put those
into okay so now I'll say this is how
many places to put the bees
okay how many ways to put the beat and
this is how many ways to choose what
should I put in the remaining
pigeonholes okay how many ways to fill
remaining spots okay so even I have
these other two to choose from if I were
to extend the length of the word as I'm
about to do in the next part right
what's going to change is this power up
here right it was 2 in this case it'll
be 3 generally speaking it's going to be
yeah and mine is true because I start
with however many letters and then I
take 2 out of action right so 4 minus 2
this is the 2 or 5 minus 2 uses 2 3 and
so on so that's my general case so now I
just put the B's that the non B's
together has motions so my total number
of ways to get to B's
here's that times yes so there's my son
for now okay let's move on to the next
part given the same conditions so ends a
positive integer that's a multiple of
two and even okay so same conditions so
you can actually see as well like this
is a big clue that not only am I gonna
have to use this part then I just worked
out I'm gonna have to use this part
because it's got the same it's got the
same conditions applied to it right so
whenever you see the conditions match
are you like okay I'm gonna need to use
this part and this part together okay
as it happens we don't get to this right
to the very end but we're still the
debenture sure that if this is the case
then the number of words of n there's
right
officers okay sir and then our words and
what conditions are applied to them with
zero or an even number of bees zero two
four six and so on bees so that's a lot
more options
they've gone number one they've changed
it from 4 that is 2 and lettuce right
and then they've changed this from just
that single case 2 to a whole bunch more
cases soon okay so that's what makes
this really hard to like it's the you
remember how we talked before about how
when a problem is lists of one
manageable you can see the logic of
what's going on and then you apply to a
general case and that's what it gets
higher and then they say well here's the
result that number should be this so
let's tackle it one step at a time
oh let's come back to this let's come
back to this so this is the total ways
before there'll be two bees in a four
letter word right so now let's as we
were starting to do before let's
generalize this thing okay if it was
like four letter word button and then a
word what things are going to change and
the answer is we'll clear that formal
change because this was I have four
spots to fill before and I won't put to
choose two of them so now I'm actually
choosing from
okay and as we noticed before this part
here came from how many are there
alphabet choices I had that's still the
same and this comes from now how many
places do I have to put those other
non-b letters in the interesting advance
to now from here the great thing about
this is we've generalized once so now I
can go to the other cases you see so if
I want to go up right to say
what if I have actually because of the
way I played and I'll go this way if I
go down and say what if I have boobies
that's this first case here that's
pretty important to establish right so
to have zero bees enter another word
it's like oh look
first I have to choose how many places
will have bees in them all right I have
n pigeon holes to choose from and I
don't want any of them so that's how
many spots for bees and then I have to
place the rest of them right so that'll
be 2 to the power M minus 0 right which
is yeah and you think about this in your
of course this makes sense because this
means that I have a or seen a or C a or
C n times and this of course is just one
Cynthia it works so far whenever you
generalize you test it out with a case
to make sure it works and then you keep
going so that was going down to zero
base if I go up to four bins okay what
changes again it's still n choose but
I'm like okay now I want to reserve four
of these pigeonholes to have bees in
them right and then I have to fill the
rest of them I've got two options to
filter the rest of them how many pigeon
holes are left after I've knocked out
four for the x-rays Edwards okay so now
you can see this is starting to form a
pattern okay it's starting to fall so
Seagram annotation view right that's
where it's going to go okay so if I add
this all up I'll leave that on the board
even though I should be going down but
I've got space system is good right to a
different quality indicator oh wait I
should have done one more thing this
doesn't actually go forever
does it there's actually an end point
right which is what if all of them are
bees okay well I'm going to out of my
head pigeon holes I will reserve all of
them to be bees right now I have two
options to fill saw the pigeon holes in
how many Peter has a left immediately is
done and you're like oh gosh
this is 1 this is 1 there is brilliant
one way to put all these humans okay
right so that's better now I have the
whole series here okay so this is my
total I'm just using that to say a song
okay it's gonna be this Plus this Plus
this Plus this and so on right so it'll
be issues bought to the end and to the N
minus 2 inches for dot dot dot because
it'd be 6 next and then where I'm going
to end is this case here and she's okay
so far so good